the nfr is back in las vegas thousands
expected to attend what is a 10-day
event starts tomorrow and offers
something for everybody yeah there's the
rodeo there's shopping concerts
christian casadas joining us now live
from fremont street experience where the
celebrations are well underway hi
christian
[Music]
hey there guys well this is truly a big
event that really is a 24 7 event now
there are over 60 artists that are
expected to keep the crowds dancing and
entertained over the next couple of days
jordan davis kicking things off here
just a few minutes ago with a
pre-concert but for one family this
rodeo is extra special
oh i'm so proud of him i'm nervous but
we get through it myrtle begay and her
family are thrilled for the national
final rodeo because her son derek will
be competing this year as a parent you
know you sit there with pride and
you know support
just being a mother i'm very proud of
him the 10-day rodeo is expected to
attract thousands back to las vegas
after the pandemic moved the event to
dallas last year michael mack helped
with the planning of the event and says
fans are in for a treat there are
enhancements every year
to the nfr and fans will see a lot of
those enhancements on the first night
but it's fine-tuning everything there'll
be a different opening obviously every
night fans will also have a wide
selection of apparel at the las vegas
convention center's cowboy christmas and
even some quick options steps away from
the rodeo it's getting chillier now in
vegas so like hoodies and then also
we have these really sweet vests that
are all leather we like to spend a
little bit of time out there
we like to come to the performances each
and every night that's that's obviously
why we come a day and night packed event
that for many is known as the super bowl
for cowboys but for this family their
focus is clear he's been rhodion for a
long time now so he's
he's pretty prepared and we're here to
support him
all right back out here live you can see
that the music here has many folks
dancing and some of these folks they've
got moves let me tell you all right the
plaza hotel is welcoming the rodeo back
with a fireworks show that's happening
tonight at eight o'clock and of course
several activities over the next week
and of course we have everything listed
on our website that's 8newsnow.com